KEN HOETMER: Let's
get started.
So my name is Ken, and
this is Brett.
And what we want to do is to
spend a little time with you
to talk about "Our Maps Your
Business-- a Guide for Using
Our Enterprise Products."
We're part of the--
well, at least I am--
part of a group of Google called
Maps for Business.
And in Maps for Business, we do
a number of things beyond
building out the Google Maps
APIs that you would most
likely be familiar with.
We also offer premium licenses
for those APIs.
So for instance, if you need
SLA or premium support, you
can buy that from us, as well
as we offer licenses for a
number of the use cases that
are currently prohibited by
the terms of use, such as asset
tracking or charging for
your application.
So we have a number of customers
who have these kinds
of Maps for Business,
or enterprise
agreements, with us.
And actually, a couple of the
ones in the Sandbox--
Nintendo and Mercedes--
are these kinds of customers.
We also offer products like
Earth Enterprise and Maps
Engine Portal, which Sean
just talked about
in the earlier session.
And then we also offer a number
of products that are
focused on managing
geographic data.
And those are the products that
we're going to talk about
in this session now.
So just in case you've fallen
asleep because you're
attending a talk about
enterprise, I thought I would
talk about a couple things why
this actually might be
relevant to you, and
why enterprise
doesn't need to be boring.
And the first assertion that
I'm going to make is that a
start-up is an enterprise.
And the enterprise term gets
bandied around as being, I
think, often associated with
big established companies.
But a small company that isn't
established yet is just an
enterprise that hasn't reached
its hockey-stick moment.
And the second is that--
especially true, I think,
if you're here at this
conference--
is that your enterprise has
location data of some form.
Bricks-and-mortar companies
have databases of customer
addresses, which using a
geocoder, you can turn into
location data.
But if you're here at this
conference-- at a tech
conference, and you're a
technology company--
you're working on mobile
in some fashion.
You've seen that's been one of
the major themes of this
conference.
And nothing else, based on the
attendance at the Android
sessions with lineups
outside the door.
And this location data in a
mobile world tends to come
from the mobile devices that
are distributed around,
whether your application
is on it, or your
workers are using them.
They're generating information
about the location of things
at a very rapid rate.
And that's a different kind
of data than we're used to
managing in terms of location.
And then the last point, which
should be obvious, but the
Maps API doesn't manage data.
The Maps API is on a million
different websites, and all of
those different websites, for
the most part, are managing
their own data in
some fashion.
If you're dealing with databases
of addresses, which
was the original Maps API
mash-up kind of data, that can
often be stored in
an SQL database.
And you use a bounding box query
to populate your map.
And you naively would
get a map like this.
But when you move into a more
mobile world, you get a
different kind of data that's
much more complicated and
comes in at much
higher volume.
And so you need to have a
solution for that data.
So what we're going to talk
about are three different
enterprise products that we
offer as part of the Maps for
Business group at Google.
And the first is Google
Maps Coordinate.
And Google Maps Coordinate is a
product released last year,
which is an out-of-the-box
application.
This is not actually an
API product, per se.
This is a ready-to-use product
that involves mobile apps for
Android and iOS, as well
as a dispatcher
dashboard for the web.
And what it allows you to
do is mobile workforce
management.
So you can dispatch jobs to
people who are out on the
field using the app.
And they can check into jobs
and then send you back
information from the field.
This is live and used by a
number of customers around the
world, one of which is the San
Francisco 49ers, here in the
Bay Area, whose security team
and the team that manages all
of the logistics on the road
actually use this to work out
picking up players from
hotels, and picking up
equipment, and that sort
of thing to coordinate
themselves.
That's why it's called
Coordinate.
The second product we'll talk
about is called the Google
Maps Tracks API.
And this has been mentioned in
a couple other sessions, but
the tracks API is a
data-oriented API product that
is about storing, analyzing,
and visualizing assets.
It uses Google Cloud to store
that information.
These assets could be anything
from trucks,
to people, to whales.
Whatever you can put a GPS
device on, you could use the
Google Maps Tracks API.
And then lastly, we'll talk a
bit about the Google Maps
Engine platform, which is our
more all-purpose Cloud GIS.
It leverages the power of
Google's Cloud to store your
spatial data and provides a
number of different services
around that, as well as an API,
which we actually just
launched last week and haven't
been talking about a lot
publicly, but we'll talk
a bit about here in
this session today.
And by the way, just to
reiterate, we're giving away
free trial accounts to Google
Maps Engine Platform at this
conference.
So if you just head over to the
Sandbox, there are people
there who can sign you up and
get you started right away for
a trial account for Maps
Engine Platform.
Great, so what we're
going to do--
and to walk you through
these products that
we're going to discuss--
is we're going to walk you
through different stages of a
fictional start-up of Brett
and I's called CatWalkr.
So Brett and I spend a
lot of time online
being Google employees.
And of course, that means we
watch a lot of videos of cats.
So we figured we'll have a
start-up about walking cats.
And we got started on this
a couple months ago.
And we realized very quickly
that it had a core problem,
and that's that cats sleep.
They don't walk.
So we pivoted, like all
successful start-ups before
us, and now our company
is called DawgWalkr.
And we've done a little more
research on DawgWalkr.
We've worked out there are 500
million dogs on the planet,
and dogs do like to walk.
So we reckon this one is going
to be massively successful.
So the first thing we want to do
to digitize the dog-walking
space is we're going to go out
and hire 10 dog walkers.
We're going to hire them on a
contract basis, and we're
going to put up a simple web
form where people can fill in
their details about their dog
and when they want it walked.
And that web form is going to
use a Google Maps Coordinate
API to create jobs in
the dispatch screen.
And then we're going to use
the Coordinate mobile
applications that our 10
dog-walkers will use to
actually manage the jobs and
take these dogs for a walk.
At this point, I'm going to flip
it over to Brett, who's
going to show you a demo.
BRETT MORGAN: Thank you, Ken.
So due to the nature of Wi-Fi
here at Moscone, I'm going to
be showing you a video
version of this demo.
This demo does actually work.
I'm quite happy to show it to
you if you come over to the
Sandbox afterwards.
So just to set this up, it's
a series of videos.
The first one is basically going
to show you that there's
nothing in the Coordinate admin
interface, so there's no
jobs waiting.
We'll then go to a separate
tab, and I'll become Bob.
Bob has a need to get his
dog Fluffy walked.
He'll put in these details, and
then we'll come back and
see the dispatch of that
job to a walker.
So there we are.
We have no jobs.
I've got Bob putting his name,
his dog's name, and
importantly, getting the address
of this wonderful
location here at Moscone
autocompleted.
And you can see the secondary
feedback on the right.
He's got a phone number.
The phone number also gets
handed off to the Coordinate
mobile application to allow the
mobile worker to actually
contact Bob directly.
And of course, Fluffy
loves to run around.
Now we go back to the
admin interface.
The admin interface--
you can see there's no jobs, and
suddenly there is a job.
So the first thing the
dispatcher does is dispatch
the job to a worker.
Suddenly the mark on the
map has changed color.
We've now got a job, and now
we're going to switch across
to the mobile workers'
application.
So this, in this case,
is a pretend iPhone.
We're all mobile developers
these days.
So here we've got--
waiting for a job.
Job comes in.
You react to it.
You actually look at the job,
figure out the details and go,
yes, I will accept this job.
And then you walk to the
location here at Moscone and
go, I have the dog.
I've accepted the job.
I checked in, and then we're
back to the admin interface.
What we can see here is the fact
that the mark was on the
map, and it's about to change
color, notifying the dispatch
center that the dog has
been picked up.
It's a little quick, this one.
So now that we've done that,
we've taken Fluffy for a walk
around Moscone Center.
And we're handing Fluffy
back to Bob.
And so what we need to do on
the mobile interface is
basically complete the job.
This means that we've completed
the workflow.
There's no more that needs
to be done here.
And the team back at home base
get notified the job is
complete, and there's no
more jobs waiting.
So--
that one.
KEN HOETMER: Here you go.
BRETT MORGAN: Thank you.
So what do we actually
see there?
We had a nice little web form
with a little bit of
information.
There were three integrations
with Google Maps.
The first one was
our autocomplete
API, which is important.
It gets us coordinate
information.
The second integration was the
map on the right-hand side
that was showing the
user where we
thought his address was.
This is important for the user
to understand that we actually
know what's going on.
And thirdly, the one that the
user didn't see was the post
back to Coordinate to actually
get the job in
train, in the workflow.
So looking at the
integration--
because this is the one call
you need to make to us that
makes it all work-- the first
two are parameters, our client
ID API key.
This is all to do with our
discovery-based APIs.
If you've integrated with any
of Google's APIs in the last
two years, you probably
know these and love
these inside out.
If you haven't, again, come and
hassle me in the Sandbox
afterwards.
I'll quite happily walk you
through getting through our
Discovery API bootstrap, and
whichever client library you
want to use, and all
that sort of thing.
The next one is a Coordinate
team ID.
This is the identifier so we
know which team to send the
job to dispatch it.
Our documentation walks through
where to find that.
So you make a post back to our
servers at this address, and
you pass us some information.
The first important one
is the lat and long.
This is why integrating with
something like autocomplete to
get the correct lat and long
is very important, because
that is the gold.
We want change this.
It's where your workers
will get sent by
their mobile phone.
The next chunk of information is
all the information around
it to give the worker context.
So the name of the guy he's
going to get the dog from, the
action he's carrying out, the
phone number that Bob put in--
all of this gets passed off to
Coordinate here and, thus,
turns up on the mobile phone.
And on to Stage 2.
Thank you, Ken.
KEN HOETMER: Perfect.
So it's worth noting that Google
Maps Coordinate is
already being used by a number
of people around the world
outside of the San
Francisco 49ers.
And we actually sell it
like Google Apps,
on a per-user basis.
So you don't need to be a
massive telco with thousands
of workers in order to use it.
You can use it with 10
people just handily.
So let's move on to Stage 2
of our fictional company.
And in Stage 2 we're going
to build a marketplace.
So Stage 1 was all about us
running a little local
business to walk dogs,
essentially.
And the second is we actually
want to take this uber style
and completely decentralize
and take it global.
So what we want to do is build
one mobile application that
walkers and dog-owners can use
to find each other and to
organize dog walks.
And the desires we have for this
mobile application is we
want transparency between the
walkers and the dog-owners,
and that means we want real-time
dog location.
And we want to be able to
visualize the walks on a map
as they're happening.
And in order to do this, we're
going to need a data storage
solution for the crumbs
that are coming
from the mobile phones.
And Google Maps Coordinate, at
this point, becomes less
ideal, because we actually don't
want a dispatcher in the
center of this.
We want this to be decentralized
and working more
on a peer-to-peer basis
between the users.
So the product that we're going
to use is the Google
Maps Tracks API.
So we can gather crumbs
from the mobile
phones as they're out.
As the walkers are out walking
the dogs, we can push those up
to the Google Maps Tracks API.
And then on the dog-owner side,
we can actually send
requests to the Tracks
API to pull down that
information in real time.
Do you understand that?
So there's a hand-off of
the data up to the
cloud and back down.
And the Tracks API will handle
all of that for you at scale.
So I'll flip it over now to
Brett, who's going to walk us
through a demo of this piece.
BRETT MORGAN: Aha, pressed
the right button again.
So again, we're going to do
a couple of videos here.
So we've got two applications.
One of them is going to
be Android based.
This one is the dog owner.
And the other one is iOS based,
and that's going to the
dog walker.
So I'm effectively avoiding all
the chrome that you need
to put on your app so that
people use it-- the good
copyrighting, the wonderful
design--
because I'm an engineer.
I'm just focusing in on the core
aspect, which is getting
the crumbs up to Tracks API and
querying them back down to
effectively do near real-time
tracking of Fluffy.
So kicking it off.
What we have here is Bob playing
with a Android tablet
trying to find the keys.
We also see that we have a
different autocomplete, but it
is Google Places API, to turn
around and make sure that the
address and the location
is correct.
Please turn around and use an
API like this that gives the
use real-time feedback on
what they're typing in.
Don't force them to
press a button to
autocomplete an address.
The next thing we see here
is Android Maps.
It's a nice and shiny API, a
nice and shiny map look.
And let's go across the iOS.
So here we've got
the dog walker.
The dog walker is waiting for
dogs, and he gets notified
that there's a dog that needs
to be walked, clicks on the
button, and now--
well, I was actually going
to take you all down the
escalator and around Moscone,
but I was figuring due to time
constraints that maybe getting
you all afternoon exercise in
the middle of our talk
wasn't the best idea.
So we're just pretending to go
for a walk around Moscone.
And if we were to bring up
Bob's machine at the same
time, we would see a little
bit of lag due to the
realities of light travel and
all that sort of thing.
But Bob could see his dog--
or more importantly,
his dog walker--
out on the path.
So he doesn't have to get
worried that the dog walker is
just going down to the coffee
house and drinking three or
four lattes before bringing
his dog back.
So actually having a look at
the aforementioned crumbs--
here's the actual information
that you
push off to our servers.
It's actually a fairly simple
piece of JSON, where you're
basically telling us how
confident you are of the
location, which you get from
your mobile device, if there
are APIs in there to find that
out, a location where you are
on the planet, and timestamp
is an epoch.
You can also add other data that
you can then turn around
and feed into our other APIs.
KEN HOETMER: Great.
So it's worth noting that the
Tracks API is an API that you
can pick up and use for free for
a limited number of assets
and a limited number
of tracks.
So you don't have to wait or
contact our sales people.
This is a product that has,
to a certain limited
feature set, is free.
And then if you want to build
something more involved that's
going to involve a lot
more data, then it
becomes a paid product.
And it was an API that we
just launched last year.
So go play with it.
We want to move down to Stage
3, and Stage 3 is where we
talk about the Google Maps
Engine Platform.
So we're going to assume now
that our product is launched.
Our mobile app is out there.
And we have dogs and
walkers happening,
but we want to grow.
In order to do this, we want to
find a way to correlate dog
parks in the area with
demographic data to try to
find where we think there's a
hot spot that we might want to
go out and do some walk around
and do some advertising.
So what we want to use
for this is the
Google Maps Engine Platform.
The Google Maps Engine
is, as I mentioned
earlier, a Cloud GIS.
And it accepts data in a large
number of formats.
Whether it's shapefile, or
GeoJSON, or whatever, you can
upload it into Google
Maps Engine.
You can create layers out of
that, and then you can overlay
those layers on top of each
other in order to create an
interesting visualization.
So that's what we're going
to show you now.
And we're actually going to flip
to a live demo this time.
Because we're not using mobile
devices, and we can be wired
into the network.
And Brett's going to walk
you through this piece.
BRETT MORGAN: OK.
So a little bit of unusual
at this stage--
we've actually got
a live web demo.
Now our theory--
KEN HOETMER: Hey,
are you using
google.maps.visualRefresh
= true?
BRETT MORGAN: I am.
Look at this.
It's all shiny.
It's all new.
KEN HOETMER: Sorry.
Quick plug.
BRETT MORGAN: So here's
San Francisco.
I'm a Sydneysider, so I don't
know it that well.
But diving into our data, we've
come up with a thesis.
And our thesis is, well, we've
got a bunch of dog parks, and
we're wondering, what does
San Francisco look like?
So what's the best way
to understand a city?
Well, that would
be census data.
Has anyone here actually played
with census data?
You'll quickly discover that it
comes in a shapefile with
lots of stuff in it.
And oh my God, trying to
understand what's in it, it's
a bit of a pain.
So what you really need is a
way to query that data and
basically go, given a set of
attributes over a chunk of
data, how do I look at it?
So what we can do--
and this is a completely custom
dashboard that I built
on top of jME API.
So it's basically firing SQL
LIKE where queries at our
servers to actually figure
out what's going on.
KEN HOETMER: And that's what
you've done-- before you move
into the census bit-- that's
how you got the
markers on the screen.
So these are all the dog
parks in San Francisco.
BRETT MORGAN: Yep, sorry.
Thank you, Ken.
KEN HOETMER: Yes, please explain
the dog parks to me.
BRETT MORGAN: OK, the dog parks
are pulled from SF Rec
Park, where we've got a list of
dog parks, constructed that
as a KML file, and put that into
our servers so that we
can then turn around and do
things like "dog parks near a
point." At this point, I've just
pulled all the dog parks
in San Francisco and put them on
the map using markers using
a wonderful little thing
called GeoJSON.
So it's really easy to walk
through in JavaScript.
So diving into our data, we've
got a theory that there are
parts of San Francisco that
have a whole lot of 30- to
39-year-olds.
And what just happened?
Zooming out a bit so we can
actually see what's going on.
Here we've got San Francisco.
And suddenly level I've
overlayed on it the
census-tracked blocks that have
a large concentration of
30- to 39-year-olds.
The interesting thing here is
that that was quick, it was
painless, and I'm not actually
storing any data on my laptop
to make this happen.
I've fed the shapefile
into the GME.
And now I'm firing queries
against it so that I can look
at age, race, and whatever
else the census data
tells me about it.
KEN HOETMER: So you could just
change those numbers there,
and it would fire off
another query.
BRETT MORGAN: Certainly can.
KEN HOETMER: And you'd get
different data back.
So--
BRETT MORGAN: So if you're--
KEN HOETMER: --You're
not kidding me.
BRETT MORGAN: --Looking for 20-
to 20-year-olds, then we
get a different view
of San Francisco.
KEN HOETMER: Great.
So based on this data, where
would you recommend I go out
on Saturday and hand
out flyers?
BRETT MORGAN: I'm thinking
there's this little cluster of
parks here with a whole bunch
of middle-aged people.
I'm thinking they're probably
wrapped up doing start-ups.
UPS I think that's where
we should go.
KEN HOETMER: All right.
So 30- to 39-year-olds living
near dog parks-- seems to be a
cluster in that area.
They're probably the kind
of people that have
more money than time.
So that's where we'll
go hand them out.
We'll do a tour of those dog
parks on the weekend.
BRETT MORGAN: Yep.
KEN HOETMER: Great.
Fantastic.
BRETT MORGAN: So diving into
what just happened.
Again, it's another
discovery-based API, so we've
got an API key.
The more important part
are these IDs.
These IDs are actually
from jME.
So when you upload a chunk of
data and create a vector
table, it will turn around
and give you an asset ID.
With this asset ID, you can
then turn around and query
against jME.
So there's a couple of queries
that I've got here.
The first one was the
dog park URL.
So this one is the markers.
We're just requesting a
straight dump of those
markers, and turning around and
walking through them, and
putting on the screen as
points on a screen.
KEN HOETMER: Just
a quick question
before you go on here.
I'm the product guy, so I have
an idea, which is I would love
to show all of those dog parks
in the mobile app so that the
walkers know where a
dog-friendly park is to go
walk their dog.
Is that possible?
Could I use the same
thing to do that?
BRETT MORGAN: Absolutely.
This is--
KEN HOETMER: A staged
question.
BRETT MORGAN: Well,
not really.
Didn't practice it before.
I like it written down
in triplicate.
OK, so yes, you can make those
queries from mobiles.
You can do things like "points
near." so you can turn around
and go as a mobile app, I'm
currently at this location.
Tell me the dog parks that are
close to me and have jME API
do the distance calculations
for you.
KEN HOETMER: It'd be a similar
kind of integration.
BRETT MORGAN: Just pointing
out that this is just a
straight AJAX call.
There's no magic here.
The more interesting query,
from my point of view--
and this is kind of new
for us, as a company I
mean, not for jME--
we have the ability to do SQL
LIKE where queries against our
data, which means we can turn
around and filter based on the
attributes of the points,
or paths, or parcels of
land, in this case.
So what we're doing here is the
query interface builder
that you saw at the top left of
my screen before is being
used to create SQL LIKE queries
and go, show me a
chunk of San Francisco
where this value is
between two nine points.
KEN HOETMER: So I can upload a
data that has all sorts of
different kinds of metadata in
it to Google Maps Engine--
like a whole different series of
essentially column names--
and then I can run like greater
than, less than, other
kinds of binary queries via
the API on that data, my
custom data.
It's not restricted to--
BRETT MORGAN: Absolutely.
Like the good old
days, really.
KEN HOETMER: Proper database.
All right.
So just a few conclusions
and parting thoughts.
Because that ends our demo
of Google Maps Engine.
The first is that you always
need more than a maps API.
You always did.
Any mashup that's been built
has always had to have some
sort of back end, whether or
not it was a simple files
stored on your server that you
pulled in, or it was something
more complex, like an SQL
database that you're trying to
run queries on, or you're using
PostGIS, or you're using
something of that form.
You always need more than a maps
API when you're building
an application to do
with location.
And the second is plan for a
large amount of location data,
especially if you're working
in the mobile space.
These phones, devices that are
out there-- even if it's not a
phone, even it's just a
dedicated cheap GPS device--
is going to be generating
a lot of crumbs.
And those crumbs are actually at
high volume and take a bit
of effort to store.
So even if you're a small
organization, you should
probably plan from the
beginning, just because of the
volume of this, to scale.
And so think about that when
you're designing your product.
And last is we have some
questions now, but stick
around for the fireside chat
that we're having after this
session with the larger portion
of the Google Maps API
Team, where we'll be happy to
answer all sorts of questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRETT MORGAN: If you'd
use the mike, please.
KEN HOETMER: The talk is being
recorded, that's why.
We could hear you, but the
people online watching later
on YouTube won't be
able to hear you.
AUDIENCE: Right.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I have a question regarding
the user data.
So right now the user data can
only be in JSON format.
Is there any way for you to
actually accept a banner user
data, like a specific point, I
have a special image assigned
for that dog, for example.
KEN HOETMER: Are you speaking
about the Google Maps Engine
Platform, or Tracks
API, or specific--
AUDIENCE: Like a [? mixed ?]
engine platform, like your dog
walker program.
Like an owner wants to
actually send an
image of the dog.
KEN HOETMER: Yeah, so that's
a very good question.
We don't have, at the moment,
support for images.
You could potentially store the
image elsewhere, and then
send a link to the image, and
then store the link to the
image as a bit of text.
So that might be a way
to get around it.
But we're not in our products
tier to store
the location data.
We don't have the ability at
the moment to store large
volumes of binary data
alongside it.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Got it.
Thank you
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
By the way, very impressed with
the new version of Maps.
It's some good things, but some
bad things, and I'll give
you conjecture on the side.
But one thing from a developer's
perspective, we
can't use the new
Maps API yet.
We're still using the
old versions of it.
And so my question is
more fundamental.
We can take KML data and
actually just insert it into
Google Maps and have it
displayed in googlemaps.com.
Or we can do these APIs
and have our own site.
So KML's one segue to getting
data onto Google Maps, and
there may be other ways.
I'm not sure.
I haven't evaluated them.
But my question's more
fundamental.
Are you encouraging mid-level
developers, not high-level
development companies--
we're a marketing company,
as you might tell--
would you encourage us to
continue to do our own maps
deployments on our own servers,
and our own websites,
and our own maps apps on our
Android phones, or to leverage
things like KML and going
into maps.com?
KEN HOETMER: So I think
there are a couple
angles to this question.
The first is KML is a
data-exchange format.
That's a standard, and is
supported by at least Google
Maps Engine.
Tracks API is about crumbs, so
it's not dealing with KML
files, specifically.
And so that's generally
supported in our API products.
Now whether or not you want to
store the data yourself on
your own servers or use our
cloud storage platforms to
store that data, I think, is
a separate question and is
related to your business.
But I think KML as the exchange
format is really
about how you communicate,
whether you're communicating
with your own server or you're
communicating with our server.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
KEN HOETMER: You can then
use KML to visualize--
AUDIENCE: But I guess my point
is the control of the map is a
lot more precise when I have it
on my own website, whereas
if I put my data as KML to
Google, I don't have the full
extent of Maps API
at my hands.
KEN HOETMER: Right, OK.
In that case, I think we're
talking about a different
question, which is, if you want
to visualize your KML
file, you can potentially upload
it to what was My Maps
and view it in maps.google.com.
That's designed generally
for consumers.
So a regular person who got a
KML file from somewhere and
wants to just visualize it, they
can potentially do that.
There's a different
question around
building your own websites.
AUDIENCE: Last question,
then, real quick.
The My Maps--
which is the next logical
question-- available in the
new preview in the new Maps
version that's being previewed
right now, or you know
if they're going to
be extending that?
KEN HOETMER: So My Maps is
currently only available in
the older version
of Google Maps.
And I can't stand here and speak
for their road map, or
I'd get in trouble when
I leave the room.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
All right.
Thank you much.
KEN HOETMER: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: I understand
the direction.
AUDIENCE: Very good on
the APIs, by the way.
BRETT MORGAN: Come and hassle
us in the Sandbox afterwards
if you've got any questions.
AUDIENCE: But you guys aren't
banking with the new version
of Google Maps?
That's not your team?
KEN HOETMER: Ask at
the microphone.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you want me to ask?
KEN HOETMER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: The question was, the
teams with the new design,
doing the new preview design for
Google Maps and the Google
Maps API team--
has the new version of Google
Maps preview been done mostly
as a back-end or more on a
front-end development?
It appears to be it's more of a
front-end development versus
the engine in the back end.
There may be some visual effects
of like expanding the
streets on the route that you're
taking, but I think
those are just mathematical
offsets that could have been
done on either front.
KEN HOETMER: So we're all
part of the larger
Geo Group at Google.
The new Google Maps is a rebuild
of Google Maps from
the bottom up.
So they're storing the data
differently, all the way from
the lowest levels to the way
they're visualizing it, where
on the Maps API, we typically
leverage the pieces that are
built for the consumer
applications.
And we're currently, at the
moment, leveraging the pieces
that were built for the existing
Google Maps, not the
preview, which is why the API
that we have is still working
on image-based maps rather than
the WebGL-based maps that
you see in the new
Google Maps.
AUDIENCE: Well, if I could put
conjecture about that design,
even though it wasn't the point
of the session, but one
of the things that you get as a
benefit of using the API is
that you can implement those
design features of the slider
and the carousel versus
a list view.
Personally, I prefer list view
for when I'm searching for
businesses and I don't know
which one I want.
But I can see how the
map interface might
work for some users.
But it's just a difference
between classic mode
versus Windows 8.
BRETT MORGAN: Thank you
for that image.
It's breaking my head.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: There's a little
time, so I'll
ask a question, too.
I just thought of it based on
another question that was
asked about photos.
So I know that right now it's
not supported to upload large
binary files in Maps Engine.
But let's say I just want to
upload them to another service
that Google offers--
either photo or video, maybe
from the YouTube API or
something--
can I specially tag those and
then somehow pull them into a
reference in a Google Map?
KEN HOETMER: Are you talking
about specifically building
your own application that would
include video or photos--
AUDIENCE: Correct.
KEN HOETMER: --That would
say location tag.
Yeah, so I was trying to
answer it in the last
question, which is that I
think you would have to
separate the storage of the
binary data from the linking
of it in the store of
your location data.
So if you, first step, took your
image and pushed it to
one of our cloud storage
options for images--
say Drive, right--
as a public image, you could
then grab the URL and store
that as metadata in the Tracks
API so that when you pulled
down that information, you
could link them together.
But remember that the Tracks
API is designed for crumbs.
So that actually, probably, as
I'm talking through this, it
doesn't make sense for you to
store images against crumbs,
unless you're snapping an image
every time something
moves, which might
not be the case.
If you're doing that, then
you'd want to do it.
Otherwise, you could,
yourself--
because this is just a back-end
component of the
application you're building--
you're going to have a database
of assets, yourself,
that you know of--
your whales.
You've got your list
of 20 whales.
And you have photos of them.
And you could store that
in your own back end.
And you just need to relate
your asset ID
in the Tracks API.
So you pass your own asset ID
to the Tracks API when you
store the crumbs.
AUDIENCE: So the access control
list that you'd use to
control access to who can see
this data, can you also apply
those to the photos,
and videos, and
other Google service?
KEN HOETMER: So in the Tracks
API, your application has
access to all of the data that
it stored in the Tracks API.
So it's not a user-level access
control function.
It's more of a back-end piece.
If you have multiple users of
your application, you could
control which tracks they're
allowed to view based on the
fact that you have
an interface that
sits in between them.
AUDIENCE: For Maps Engine,
though, because that's a
little different.
KEN HOETMER: So Maps Engine's
a different product.
We have an API that
lets you store the
data and pull it down.
We also-- this is
a good question.
Maps Engine allows you to set
who has access to your data
that you stored in the cloud and
to work together in teams.
BRETT MORGAN: Both from
viewing and editing.
They're separate ACLs.
KEN HOETMER: Right.
So but those ACLs are generally
designed for you in
your own organization and in
your own team, rather than
setting a different ACL on every
one of your end-users,
potentially, who would be using
the data that you're
serving out of it, if
that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: I think so.
KEN HOETMER: Right.
So in DawgWalkr, Brett and I
could give each other access
to the data but maybe not give
it to our finance guy, because
he'll muck with it.
But the end-users who are
walking their dogs, we would
control how they get the data
based on the interface that we
build in between.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
KEN HOETMER: All right.
Well, let's wrap up there.
Thank you.
BRETT MORGAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]